foreign
Ethan is in Asheville North Carolina hi
Ethan how are you I'm doing good how are
you doing better than I deserve how can
I help you sir well me and my wife are
thinking about considering the debt
consolidation loan we don't have any
type of credit card debt that's just
something early on we decided we didn't
want to get into
um but really all we have I guess as far
as debt or a couple vehicle loans
[Music]
the other big part of that we have is
whenever we had got our house they had
under budgeted us on our well and so we
had to borrow about ten thousand dollars
from a family member
and we have also purchased a storage
building from that family member as well
so we actually owe them right at 13.5
for everything so we're trying to figure
out if it's best to do a debt
consolidation loan for all of that or if
it would be better just to make payments
to them as we can afford it the only
thing with family
is I've seen a lot of times where your
family money and it causes issues yeah
you should have thought of that before
you bought a stupid Barn from them
that's that's my biggest thing is just
trying to figure out if we should do a
debt consolidation loan or if that's
even a good idea what is a debt
consolidation loan do it just puts it in
one pile instead of four piles
pretty much yeah doesn't change anything
well I know sometimes because we had
figured it up it was going to save about
400 a month
um no it's not
unless you stay in debt longer
okay that might be because you didn't
change your interest rate by five
thousand dollars a year on the figures
you gave me
you'd have to change your interest rate
by 10 but what kind of car loans have
you got a 19 car loan
no sir no I've got a 12 car loan and
they were going to match that at the
debt consolidation loan yeah which means
you got absolutely gain no ground so
where the 400 savings come from only one
way mathematical it could happen and
that's extend the length of the loan
okay yeah that's what it was I believe
yeah yeah why you want to be in that
longer
well just because it was going to save
us a little bit of money I guess no it
didn't it saves you money per month it
didn't save you money you're gonna be in
debt longer and it's gonna cost you more
money because you're gonna pay interest
longer
now that completely makes sense yeah so
what's your household income
well I'm self-employed my wife is a
stay-at-home mother what do you mean it
was profit was 70 000 last year okay you
guys roll up your sleeves don't go to
restaurants and don't go on vacation you
get this crap cleaned up what do you owe
on these cars
well I've got I've got a truck payment
and it's 16 000. we've got a Honda CRV
payment it's 5500 is what we owe left on
it then we've got a personal loan to
borrow
um for a vehicle we got when we got the
vehicle the transmission went out so we
had to also borrow for that and the
total of that personal loan is 6 500.
yeah okay
you're driving an awfully nice truck for
this mess
um so yeah you got you know you got what
forty five thousand dollars including
all the family junk and you make 70 and
so it's going to take you two years of
living on beans and rice rice and beans
and you'll be done
right list these debts smallest to
largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one attack the
little one like your freaking life
depends on it
okay and go get your life back and quit
borrowing money for the stupid stuff
yes sir it did not bring you Joy
right yeah so next time you need a truck
don't buy one unless you have the money
be like your grandpa don't buy it unless
you can afford it yeah you know I'd like
to see them beyond what you said I'd
like to see them jump start this and if
it's me I'm I'm looking if I've got some
equity in that truck I'm selling it uh
I'm working extra hours we are in the
best part-time economy as it relates to
jobs we've ever seen Dave in the history
of America he can go make some money I
jump start this and you know let me ask
you this can cause you talk about the
jobs part all the time and from the very
first day we started teaching Financial
Peace University 30 years ago we've told
people get an extra job and it used to
be we tell them to deliver pizza yeah
now everybody seems to be delivering
food yeah ubereats right
um
and I'm not against Uber Eats or
doordashing or any of that that's all
fine it's an easy thing to plug in and
plug out right you can log in log out
just keep rocking you can manage your
own hours I'm not convinced it is the
most profitable part-time job it's not
and what are they yeah so they are
you're looking for manual labor
positions And what I mean by manual
labor does it mean shoveling or using a
hammer but if they just need a body to
stock shelves in warehousing
manufacturing right now is really really
strong they're paying more than you can
make doing Uber Eats yes much more
because if you go work for Walmart or a
Target or a big box store and you're
working off hours so he's got a
full-time job he's running his own
business how can I pick up 20 hours a
week let's just rule of thumb they pay
in that places 16 18 to 20 an hour
depending on where you're depending on
where you are so you gotta look the
point is don't just assume I'm gonna go
drive here's the thing I was talking to
when we were in Salt Lake City the other
day I was talking to a group and uh just
standing around at one of our events and
one of them was telling me
stinking babysitter
yes is getting 30 bucks an hour that's
true let me tell you what he bucks for
babies dog walking yes for the lady was
on here yesterday to enter that free
screen yes 30 minutes for 30 yes rich
people don't even walk their own dog
that's exactly right what is this that's
right I know they're scared of leaves
that's right you get your leaf blower
you can make money because rich people
are scared of leaves but I didn't know
they don't even walk their own dog
that's right but just look in your local
economy who's having a hard time hiring
people see what they're paying this
isn't about skill this is about gazelle
and so go fill a gap and make some
really good money yeah kick your money
up drop your expenses Down clean your
mess up you can't borrow your way out of
debt that's the moral of the story of
this call that con solidation doesn't
work because you haven't fixed the
problem in your mirror